you
31 was that number and Delta Beck
guessed it okay I was its hoping to go
into the Fort Knox variation of the
French well we're probably not going to
have that now are we
no so I could play the position where
the Queen's are off but I'm gonna go
with this something different and oh the
reason why I wanted to go into that
variation is because that was my most
recent topic of my video okay now I'm
gonna take as I'm up upon that it showed
a trap in the Fort Knox variation of the
French defense so now I'm more than
happy to go forward with the Queen
exchange because at the end of it I'm up
upon and this night I could attack it
again so let me do just that I see no
reason to take this pawn fact taking
this pawn is accelerating my opponents
development I don't want to do that
so what do I want to do I want to make
sure I get all my pieces out so if they
take on e4 then I'll exchange Queens and
then I'll recapture with my knight and
now maybe I want to take because then I
could eventually force the bishop to go
back and recapture on d1 as otherwise
light will be on castled so is there
anything better than capturing on d3 no
actually yeah there is let's develop and
now now I'm threatening to win yet
another pun I want to advance my own
development I don't want to help out my
opponent from developing I guess what
seed 3 the intention is to play to d4 ok
I could capture I could also develop but
these guys are doubled let me make sure
they stay there I could have them undone
he's isolated
and I have majority now this four versus
three I can give a check let me do that
I don't really intend to capture the
night when it blocks I'm assuming white
would develop to meet this check I
really just did that however to finish
development or maybe maybe there's a
reason to pile up on the pink piece yeah
let me let me do that before maybe it is
prevented with blood side Bishop c4 so
this I'm taking a short time out here to
not advance my development but to
exploit this pin and now there's two
pieces of greater value on the same
diagonal
it's my Bishop can I make use of that
somehow I'm not considering at all the
capture of this Knight not until some
question is thrown to my bishop at least
okay now there's something going on here
now there's something going on I'm going
to defend this structure has changed
quite a bit and now I'm going to be
getting more material with Knight takes
here because this is attacked if Bishop
takes Bishop I take this rook first I'm
off a piece from this line two bishops
it's the rook f 597 to d5 come to mind
as well okay this pawn is actually hit
twice off I need to defend him with the
pawn if I want to hang on to him Bishop
here is a good home when I'm trying to
assess accurately a chess position and I
realized that in this position
I'm simply up a lot of material but
looking at the positional factors one of
the things I look at with regard to
pawns are where I have my furthest
advanced pawns and then are any of those
squares that that pond controls a hole
in the position and right now it
controls f3 and d3 but of these two it's
d3 that is a hole and so that will act
as a home for a piece in this case my
phone is missing these threats that I
have I was reacting to that a3 if I had
captured on b3 they would take on before
but pieces are just falling at this
point but going back to what I was
saying this is a great home for a bishop
but ideally a knight right here would be
enormous again assuming it was you
didn't have the imbalance this great
change in or this great difference right
now with regard to material but ideally
a knight on this square is fantastic I
like my bishops position right here so I
want to secure that watches over b5 and
I could think about Queen h4 stuff if
there's one piece that I could get
working a little bit more it would be my
knight in my opponent helps me out with
that move this is this falls into the
chasing an opponent's piece away to
square wanted to go to he would love to
play here
he's more central and now he has this
square in mind which would come with the
fork two rooks potentially our hip
Knight c4 is maybe a possibility these
jumping points where I'm already where I
already have defense
D 3 and C 4 and take this truck they
take my bishop
we'll take this okay what if I take here
I thought I would have this check but
Queen if I took with here I hear there's
Queen takes with check I can't do that
it's trying to be clever just there if
the King goes here this Queen is tied
down to the defense of e1 so I couldn't
make use of that I could maybe look to
deflect the Queen away but I have Bishop
takes pawn stuff that wouldn't be a good
idea the King goes back here h2 is
dropping 40 seconds less than 40 seconds
GG let's go back flip where is there
something to take away from this game
right here I wouldn't go with this d3
you allow me to at the very least
consider exchanging and ruining your
castling privilege so what can you do
better how about if you want something
very simple it's not going to enter
anything there's any crazy territory but
if you really wanted to establish yet
another pond in the center at this
moment right here and you can always
meet d5 with capturing and then play
Knight f3 and then Bishop d3 and then
castle develop develop development it's
the biggest thing what happened in this
game was what exactly well even he could
be more aggressive with your Bishop
you're pointing at a pond that's I have
no fear whatsoever with this diagonal
this one is a different story maybe
maybe I have to worry a little bit about
it new 5 push exploiting the pin this is
harmless this even runs into potential
in pawn advances by me
with tempo where I'm able to grab space
so steer clear of that I I don't I don't
like this idea of d3 so again going back
I would consider just establishing yet
another pond in the center and move to
or when your pond is challenged like
this with my d5 consider capturing at
that point and then playing D for
yourself establishing a
in the center for yourself that's the
biggest thing because I'm winning upon
at this point and it's way downhill your
nights getting kicked around now I'm
grabbing space c3 is into developing
move I'm developing d4 is not a
developing roof we developed there he
defended c3 but at that point it was way
too late okay good game